depending on your age yo-yo may be an
internet meme winning very young once or
a troika chief for trace either way we
can agree that Kazuya morado nails both
they call him baby yo-yo and he's an
urban legend at the tender age of six
this kid is amazing
has a six year old managed to pull this
off
obviously our experts don't know their
sleepers from their offsprings but
what's the science behind these tricks
yo-yos are all about energy transfer
because when you let go of it because
it's falling from a height that's
potential energy because you're throwing
it down that's kinetic energy and so all
of this means when it hits the end of
the string it's a third type of energy
it's now got angular kinetic energy all
of their energy has gone into making it
rotate some of these tricks are only
possible because he keeps the yo-yo
spinning that creates a gyroscopic
effect it makes it really stable it
resists any change in its direction so
he always rotates around an axis that
points in the same direction this means
that the yo-yo is gonna be very
predictable so he knows exactly where
that yo-yo is gonna be and he knows
exactly how it's gonna behave so Kazuya
transfers all the energy into spinning
powers for putting the Yolo and yoyo we
thank you